[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight never get the feeling that news
stories come and go faster than they
used to ask anyone in the news business
it's real the oj story lasted about a
year now it feels like there's a no j' a
week maybe it's the effect of staring at
screens all day jumping from snippet to
snippet our brains have been rewired to
think only in the present tense or maybe
there's just a lot more news than there
used to be some world historic crisis
hits every four days knocking the last
world historic crisis from our
collective consciousness forever once
upon a time people had a chance to
digest their disasters the titanic for
example sank in April of 1912 in 1982
the New York Times ran a front page
feature about Titanic survivors seventy
years later people still remembered the
story can you remember what happened 70
days ago about 56 days ago think back to
that cobwebs shrouded period in our
history it was January of 2019
the federal government had just shut
down the president said we needed a
border wall the Democrats scoffed at him
they claimed the entire immigration
crisis was quote manufactured the news
media heartily weighed in on that debate
in case you can't remember whose side
the media took here's a clip from our
archives folks the president has
manufactured one heck of a political
crisis for himself
Donald Trump is manufacturing a national
security crisis you will hear you're
gonna say is that this is a manufactured
crisis it's not a national security
crisis from Nancy Pelosi down to debbie
Wasserman Schultz or anybody else who
will give him a dime for this project
manufactured it's a manufactured crisis
for the president to get a political win
we have a president who will go on TV
tonight and lie and lie and lie some
more there's a manufactured crisis
altogether now manufactured crisis six
syllables learn them dear robots repeat
them until they seem plausible move on
they'll never remembered you lied and
that's exactly what they did it's what
they always do but reality has an
unpleasant habit of reinserting itself
into these things you can dismiss a
crisis as manufactured but that doesn't
mean the crisis doesn't exist in the
last month 76,000 illegal aliens crossed
the us-mexico border that's the highest
number in more than a decade that's more
than the entire population of San
Francisco or Boston or Washington DC
every single year coming by foot over
just one of our international borders
that is a crisis manufactured or not how
would people in charge responding to
this crisis well they're still lying and
not just lying because that's never
enough for them they're lying and
sneering at the same time all with
maximum self-righteousness they're
selling us a steaming load of BS and
screaming at us for not believing it
here's young pioneer Alexandria Acacio
Cortez letting you know that if you want
your border secured you're a bad
American the good Americans are the ones
trying to sneak into America the
president should not be asking for more
money to an agency that has
systematically violated human rights the
president should be really defending why
we are funding such an agency at all
those women and children trying to come
here with nothing but the shirts on
their back to create an opportunity and
to provide for this nation are acting
more in an American tradition than this
president is right now yeah they're the
real Americans well Cascio Cortez
expanded on this on Twitter last night
she denounced any Democrat who might be
tempted to compromise in any way on
immigration only open borders are
morally acceptable quote where was the
concern last week when 26 Democrats
voted for a GOP amendment to expand ice
powers rooted in the racist plus false
trope that Latino immigrants are more
dangerous than us born citizens Nicasio
Cortes continued this way quote the
entire premise of a wall is not based in
fact it's based in a racist plus non
evidence-based trope that immigrants are
dangerous yet some Dems are willing to
compromise and spend billions on a trope
because we've accepted some kind of
racism as realpolitik in America end
quote
racist white supremacist and you would
have disabuse me as with Nazi
how tired are you of screeching like
this
how boring has it become well not to
Alexandria Acacio Cortez
she thinks it's fresh and cutting edge
she thinks she's the future in fact she
was completely out of touch she has no
idea what America is like her tiny
little world of Fairtrade coffee shops
is thriving she thinks everyone lives
like her that's how closed her mind is
she is the oldest 29 year old in history
for millions of other people the country
they grew up in is crumbling bad
immigration policies not the only reason
for that but it's a major reason for it
every year in America drug overdoses
killed more Americans than the entire
Vietnam War now one of the main causes
of that is fentanyl much of which is
smuggled across the Mexican border in
all of fiscal year 2013 the feds seized
a total of two pounds of fentanyl itself
to kill 450,000 people in 2018 last year
customs seized 1747 pounds of fentanyl
that is almost 900 times as much it's
enough to kill 396 million people that's
more people than live in the United
States and Canada combined now that
bothers you are you a racist
Acacio Cortes and the rest of the morons
say yes you are everyone else
understands that borders are what make a
country if you can't control who enters
you are a failed state just this morning
DHS Secretary Kirsten Neilson put in
perspective she said that illegal
arrivals at the Mexican border are set
to hit 1 million by the end of this
fiscal year
more illegals will come in the first six
months of 2019 this year than came in
all of 2017 that's a crisis it's also a
humanitarian catastrophe today's migrant
flows have created a humanitarian
catastrophe in one study more than 30
percent of women reported sexual assault
along the way and 70% of all migrants
reported experiencing violence very
unfortunately because of the increase in
violence at ice when we have families
with children we have to give every girl
pregnancy test over ten this is not the
safe journey
wait what
it's not safe to walk through the
Sonoran Desert migrants get raped trying
to sneak into America you must be a
racist if you think that quick somebody
tells CNN so they can denounce Nielsen
as a white supremacist someone like
believer otherwise meanwhile the border
degrades unaccompanied minors keep
showing up here word has gotten out that
almost nobody will ever be deported from
this country just claim asylum and get
released everyone in Central America
knows this why wouldn't they since 2000
the number of pending immigration court
cases has gone from barely a hundred
thousand to more than 800,000 about 22
million illegal immigrants already live
in the United States that's more people
than the populations of 16 US states
combined that is more than the entire
New York City metropolitan area just of
people here illegally but remember it's
not a crisis it's a guaranteed
Democratic majority for the next hundred
years and that's a good thing as CNN